une question on vous trouve l'info
bonjour françois mon nom et juliette
j'ai une question pour vous je me suis
acheté une voiture dernièrement et j'ai
entendu que si je voulais éviter d'avoir
des problèmes avec ma garantie il était
préférable
les femmes du changement d'huile les
inspections chez mon concessionnaire
plutôt qu'au garage du oui madame la
liberté même si votre concessionnaire
aimerait beaucoup que vous vous rendiez
chez lui pour votre entretien
vous êtes libre d'aller où google et
même si votre entretien et ferrarone
indépendant et non par un
concessionnaire de la marque
les constructeurs vont honorer leurs
garanties nous avons appelé deux
associations canadiennes de
manufacturiers qui représente
pratiquement tous les constructeurs
elles sont formels leurs membres ne
peuvent pas vous obliger à faire
l'entretien chez eux
au québec c'est même une exigence de la
loi sur la protection du consommateur
par contre un conseil conserver vos
factures détaillées
parce que votre contrat vous oblige à
bien entretenir votre voiture
jesse caron c'est à québec
c'est aussi simple que ça pour
l'entretien vous allez où vous voulez
passer le mot
[Musique]